a vital threat to humanity that's how
the leaders of Brazil and Colombia are
describing the threat to their greatest
natural treasure the Amazon rainforest
my government is committed to ending
deforestation by 2030. this is a
commitment that Amazonian countries can
take on together in the Bellum plan
there is a lot of work we can cooperate
on
deforestation in the Amazon is at record
levels despite commitments by
governments and companies across the
region to stop it and it's coming
dangerously close to being 20 destroyed
a threshold which experts say would be a
point of no return
Colombian president Gustavo Petro said
rich countries should contribute to a
fund to support farming communities
who've been clearing forests to create
cattle
how much will they pay us for it why not
do the same as those in the north did
the northern people wiped out the
forests and killed the indigenous people
is that development do we have to do the
same or is there an entirely different
perspective
before arriving at the meeting Brazil
announced a 33 reduction in
deforestation since president Lula
returned to office six months ago but
experts say is not enough after the
devastation caused during jahir
bolsonaro's Administration which
weakened environmental restrictions
not to underestimate a problem that has
been accumulating for decades it hasn't
been a single government but many
consecutive ones that have allowed us to
reach such a high level of degradation
we could soon reach the point of no
return
foreign international criminal networks
are polluting Rivers through illegal
Mining and cutting down the forests to
expand cattle ranching and illicit crop
cultivation Colombian Brazil say more
original integration is needed to fight
against it
we will establish an international
police cooperation Center in manaus and
create an integrated air traffic control
system which will help dismantle the
route used by organized crime
the meeting laid the groundwork for a
regional presidential level Summit that
will be held in Brazil next month hoping
to implement policies that could save
one of the world's most important and
fragile ecosystems before it's too late
Alessandro Al Jazeera Bogota